final fantasy 13 was announced I was
coming to xbox 360 last year and this is
the first Final Fantasy game that will
be available for both the current-gen
consoles ps3 and xbox 360 and the battle
system has been involved so people will
see a different presentation so the
story of final fantasy is that the world
of fan fantasy 13 is split into the
futuristic see city world of Cocoon and
also outside of it there's this
wilderness called pulse and lightning
and some of the other characters that
you've seen in the trailers they were
chosen to cause destruction to cocoon
and that's the basic story flow that's
available right now we are aiming for
spring 2010 release